try to make the best uh decision as a
human not just
for yourself or yourself just first
humanity
one vote might seem as insignificant but
it is important i understand that in
numbers we have strength everybody just
needs to understand that that's what
matters i'm j.r smith and i'm voting
because my voice matters i'm your donor
tasman and i'm voting because the power
is in the people
i'm cody zeller and i am voting because
it's my right as a u.s citizen
i'm miles bridges and i am voting
because my life
voting's important to me because just so
many people's
sacrificed over the course of time my
ancestors
uh so many people who uh
didn't have the right to to vote just to
be able to say i i
did something my opinion and my voice
matters
when you look at any of these individual
um
issues in communities whether it's jacob
lake or george floyd or brianna taylor
what what's clear is that the decisions
about what happens in local communities
usually sit in the hands of elected
officials whether it's the district
attorney or the judge or the sheriff
um we get the leadership that we choose
being from florida
and understanding the importance of the
state of florida you know in the process
as soon as i got home um you know i
wanted to make a priority get right to
the polls
right there and vote um because those
are the things that we've been pushing
while we're in the bubble so i want to
make sure we keep that momentum when we
get outside
florida has a lot to do with the outcome
of the voting situation that's let's
just say that
one of the things that makes our country
unique uh compared to other countries is
that we do have a say
in who our leaders are going to be and
you know one vote might
seem as insignificant but it is
important for everyone to vote
as i hear about some of the policies it
really affects my life it's not just
picking between which two people are my
favorite my dad has
had open surgery when i was in high
school so he has a aortic valve and a
pre-existing condition
so that's one of the hot topics for for
me and my family is making sure that
he's able to get health insurance the
country we're going through a lot right
now so
it's important for everybody to get out
and vote
everybody just needs to understand that
their vote matters do you do diligence
honestly just
do you do your research take it take the
time uh
take this very seriously that's not it's
not something you just
you know walk in and breeze through you
have
more candidates than just the democratic
republicans
options to give you um it takes time and
consideration to because it affects a
lot of people it affects all of us
i understand that in numbers we have
strength in numbers we have strength
people so
um it's going to be hard you know we're
getting misinformation and confusion
um but we have strength in numbers i was
asking guys
who who's voted who's listed making sure
guys are registered at the end of the
day that's where it starts i have to
encourage
people in my community my friends my
family
making sure starting right there and
then hopefully they can
you know pass that along to somebody
else my role in the pa
is working with the players on their
philanthropy and their social impact
and a big part of that um is
civic engagement i don't think that we
were surprised to find out that um
that not all of our players were
registered i think
i think it was somewhat what we expected
uh no matter what you do
as it relates to registering for people
to vote it's it's
one man one vote one player one
registration
um and sort of methodically began doing
that about this time last year
i would say who helped me get out and
vote where my my teammates
they're they're very on that my coach
he's done a great job getting everybody
to vote
he's very involved with our swarm to the
polls on voting
he's been great throughout the whole the
whole summer um
you know making it a big point to vote
and especially get the young guys
registered and educated um he really
preaches to us
to be a complete person not just a good
basketball player oh they were a big
help um
show robert so she knew the talk to talk
to when it came to
talking to the mayor's office and the
mayor and uh
it was just very very inspiring to uh
to have the backing of the players
association more than anything
the way we think about arenas are
gathering places uh
for a lot of us or for all of us
actually there are anchors
in a lot of the neighborhoods and
communities and specifically for
jr um even though the prudential center
is no longer a place where basketball is
being played it sits right at the center
of newark
it's a part of his uh experience living
in new york
and he knew that providing it as a safe
accessible place for people
to come vote was important and he wanted
to make sure that his neighbors
and family members and community could
have that safe place
me being 40 years old now i'm really
starting to really understand all the
different ways of voting suppression and
systematic racism and for me
um i was largely voter suppressed you
know what i'm saying i didn't think my
vote even mattered if you're not having
voters conversations with your friends
um you're not being educated on voting
in school um
and then when you do get old enough to
vote how do you pick somebody that you
vote for
how are you comfortable with the person
that you're endorsing
um those are some of the things that you
know i wasn't aware of that i had to
educate myself on so now that i have
this platform it's time for me to pass
that information along the other day i'm
i'm
bigger than the basketball player so i
can honestly say i didn't take it as
serious or look at it like that
as i did in the past but obviously
everybody matures
you know at their own pace so i'm just
happy i'm on
my on the right side of it everybody has
a voice no matter if you play basketball
you still have a have a voice and just
because you play basketball you can't
just
limit somebody to just one thing in life
i feel like lebron james carmelo anthony
chris paul and all the guys they've done
a great job of setting the standard for
his younger guys and
you see guys like milk and brock then
and jaylen brown they definitely
took the torch so we just want to follow
after those guys people are going to
look back our kids are going to look
back at this and say
you are a part of that i got a
grandfather that marched next to dr king
in the 60s
and he was amazing he would be proud to
see us all here
we got to keep pushing forward what
gives me hope is just everybody is
starting to get involved now
before it would only be like a certain
amount of guys to speak out about it on
twitter and instagram
but now i feel like guys we're taking to
the streets i mean i think it's great to
see you
you see the change coming you feel the
inspiration
uh within so many young people who have
voices and know they have voices and
know that their voice
means something i think social
networking alone
has just been so connected to everybody
to where we
actually feel the pain and hurt that so
many people go through it's not just
one city or one small town or one
small community it's a it's a whole
world out here where
a lot of people feel the exact same way
unified collectively
in numbers bringing everybody together
it's been proven
it's been shown that you know we can do
it if we all do it together so
um that's what that's that's the most
encouraging thing to me watching
everybody come together in a bubble you
know that's the first time
i've been in this league 17 years that
i've watched everybody collectively on
one platform use their voice for the
same common goal
and that was amazing for me to see you
know one of the things i found
really interesting is how excited the
first time voters are
right that um that they're able to sort
of step out there and not just step out
there on their own and vote
but take their colleagues with them take
their family members with them
um i i think what we have done in our
league
is make voting a part of what it means
to be an nba player
and i think every rookie that walks into
this league at the draft
will know that even though the election
is behind us that they'll need to
register too and i'm proud